[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découvre la Réunion ensemble les paraît
alors allons-nous
comment
[Musique]
il est pas moins les misérables même
alors dans la commune d'ici Laos plus
précisément au niveau des thermes ben
c'est bien c'est que là il vient prendre
plusieurs centaines et plusieurs
endroits et ben nous on va aller à la
roche merveilleuse et bien le sentier il
est pas là allez allons-nous
bonjour monsieur dame bonjour monsieur
comment allez-vous bonjour ça va bien
bonjour monsieur bonjour alors dites-moi
vous descendez vous arrivez comme ça ah
bah on arrive de la roche des merveilles
ah c'était c'était fabuleux aussi avec
une vue panoramique sur le belvédère sur
le haut quoi c'était parfait c'est vrai
ah ouais vraiment génial et vous habitez
la Réunion même ah non pas du tout non
ah vous êtes d'où nous on habite à côté
de la Suisse à côté de Genève exactement
la Réunion alors vous connaissez
auparavant non connaissez pas mais on
avait envie de venir
et puis surtout voilà le la fournaise
entre autres les randonnées qui sont
sublimes aussi
vous avez découvert des plats à la
Réunion pas ah bah oui
les placés
merci à vous tous
[Musique]
le départ non et chef de fil des
activités de pleine nature et avec l'ONF
sont gestionnaire ben nous occupe de
tout ça fait en sorte que tous les
usages il passe bien dans le massif et
ici à silos là topo-guib que notre
produit avec 9 circuits 54 km et depuis
un an en fait nous c'est de coordonner
les usages parce que dans beaucoup
d'usages il y a beaucoup de piétons de
randonneurs mais aussi des vététistes et
ça il permet en fait de de faire en
sorte que tout se passe bien que tout le
monde ait le droit à son bol d'air frais
mais un peu toute la famille des des
bleus des vertes des rouges pour amuser
aussi un peu plus sportif il permet
vraiment à tout le monde de profiter du
massif nous les Sims à peu près on a 110
000 pratiquants vélo sur la Réunion donc
les assez important donc il faut
répondre à ce besoin pour que chacun y
profite de la pleine nature et ça c'est
le rôle du département
ben écoute ben moi mais on va voir si ça
trouve un loi de vélo et ça serait pas
mal alors là moi monsieur avec deux
trois vélos bon monsieur bonjour Comment
allez ça va bien vous-même ça va ben
ouais dis-moi oui mais si tu veux me
prêter one un petit groupe et ça va là
juste devant donc si tu veux faire un
tour exode casque le petit vélo ben
merci
[Musique]
on retrouve mon moment rien que la même
mort qui a des danses derrière Elena la
montagne ni un soleil à cross fait pipi
comme si la nature déconnait à la
paradis pour nous rester
[Musique]
comment ça va bonjour
ça va bien
bonjour bonjour Alors comment ça se fait
moi je monte vous descendez ah ben il
faut dans les deux sens dans le monde
non mais on a déjà monté là on descend
et on va remonter et où tu connais déjà
le son entier ou bien non non découverte
parce que là on a deux collègues qui
sont partis au Piton d'accord
s'ils sont beaux et puis bah les moins
bon ils peuvent tourner autour de du
cirque et puis c'est joli non mais déjà
jolie petite chose
de métropole de France d'accord et je
les ai amené va essayer dans mon pays
parce que moi je suis né là
et du coup c'est où un peu le guide
alors voilà
[Musique]
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène
un peine respect pour mon pays vraiment
d'après depuis solide la terre dans le
Paradis et ben voilà nous arrive sur le
site de La Roche merveilleuse en tout
cas ça elle est bien c'est que nous
gagnez soit fait comme on l'a fait ou
soit nous gagnons loto et ça allait bien
c'est que un bon Pecos et ben nous ça
nous a fait ce que nous savoir le point
de vue allez allons-nous
ah bah tombe bien
bonjour monsieur bonjour ça va bien
bonjour
oui alors dis-moi qu'est-ce que vous
regardez là
le point de vue vous connaissez ce site
là avant pas du tout on nous l'a
conseillé
en fait on a entendu parler du de
syllaos et du cirque on a trouvé un
hébergement sur place et c'est vraiment
après du bouche à oreille avec le
propriétaire sur place que du coup il
nous a dit allez voir la roche
merveilleuse c'est vraiment un endroit
chouette d'accord et vous habitez à la
Réunion ben vous allez en vacances pas
du tout on est des oreilles
et est-ce que c'est la roche
merveilleuse pour arriver jusqu'au point
de vue on a eu aucun souci on est
vraiment venu en voiture on s'est garé
pas trop loin et on n'a pas eu du tout
de problème quelques marche à monter
les femmes et lentilles
on a réservé une table normalement
profite bien
et pour ça rendez vous un prochain
épisode de l'émission de nous votez
la semaine à tout
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]